[Music]
straight ahead online crime daily
bombshell test results out of wisconsin
someone essential to the proceedings has
tested positive i do have to suspend our
proceedings for a period of time what's
next in the trial of chandler holderson
as a defending test positive for copen19
and developments in state and federal
cases for the three former officers
involved in the arrest and murder of
george floyd plus prince andrew is
headed to federal court a judge rules
it's too soon to dismiss sexual assault
allegations against the duke of york but
first a plea is entered for accused
michigan school shooter 15-year-old
ethan crumbly i would wave the fomo
reading stand my client mute ask that
i'm not guilty plea be entered law on
crime daily covering court cases from
coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin accused michigan school shooter
ethan crumbly appears in court virtually
entering a not guilty plea in the case
fifteen-year-old crumbly faces multiple
charges including terrorism causing
death first degree murder and assault
with intent to murder for the oxford
high school shooting in november of last
year officials say crumbly opened fire
at the school killing four students and
injuring eight others prosecutors say
his parents jennifer and james crumbly
ignored warning signs leading up to the
shooting they faced four counts of
involuntary manslaughter on wednesday
ethan crumbly appeared in court
virtually where defense attorneys waived
a formal reading of the charges and
entered a not guilty plea on his behalf
after that presiding judge kwame rowe
addressed kovan 19 concerns as a
deadline for crumbly's placement as a
juvenile looms in the coming weeks
it's my understanding that according to
the juvenile justice and delinquency
prevention act that a hearing must be
held before january 21st 2022 regarding
the placement of the defendant however
because of the pandemic we cannot
effectuate an in-person hearing um which
i believe it would be appropriate in
this case because of the high number of
covic cases of positivity rate in
oakland county
because the number of cova cases are so
high at this time the court is finding
good cause to extend those 30 days um
because we cannot effectuate in person
hearing at this time due to the
positivity rates it's my understanding
that uh defense is requesting in person
and i believe that is absolutely
appropriate in this matter
judge rowe ordered attorneys to submit
briefs on crumbly's placement he also
set a january 19th status conference for
attorneys when both sides will determine
a later date for a hearing on crumbly's
placements
joining us today is criminal defense
attorney taylor cause and terry austin
taylor what does a hearing for placement
entail and what is the defense aiming
for
uh thanks for having me guys so in this
case even though uh the defendant is
being tried as an adult he's still only
15 years old and as a result of that and
as a result of the statute that the
judge just referenced uh in that speech
he was giving before
they have to conduct a hearing on where
he will be placed and what that means is
what facility is he going to be held in
is he going to continue to be held in
the county jail where adults are held or
is he going to be moved to the
children's village where juvenile
delinquents are held and the defense
clearly wants him to be moved to the
juvenile facility for a variety of
reasons i'm sure they will harp on his
safety and welfare he is a young child
even though he did actions and acted
like an adult only 15 years old and for
him to be housed with adults of all ages
particularly with the crime that he's
committed his attorneys will argue that
he's going to be a target and that his
safety is at risk so what they're hoping
for
is that the judge agrees with this line
and shifts him over to the children's
village where his you know they believe
that they can handle him in a better way
protect him in a better way and make him
less of a target considering everybody
else around him will also be a child
makes sense terry on the civil side of
this tragedy cases are ramping up
against the oxford school as plaintiffs
are saying many red flags were ignored
what were they and do they make for
strong claims
well i do think they make for strong
claims there were a number of red flags
not the least of which we know he was
seen looking for ammunition online
apparently he brought ammo to the school
he also weeks before put a bird's head
in a jar and brought that to school so
the question is whether or not the
school should have known better and
whether or not they acted reasonably and
of course in hindsight clearly they did
not act enough yeah and right there you
just saw some photos of uh some evidence
that was put in that being ethan
crumbly's work assignments and you saw
some more red flags that should have
been caught by the school
now onto news out of colorado where
prosecutors say they could call up to
500 witnesses in the coming trial of
accused wife killer barry morphew this
comes after a new judge is appointed in
the case when judge patrick murphy
recused himself the move followed a
request by the defense to remove judge
murphy based on a previous ruling that
he was biased or prejudiced towards the
defense attorney representing morphy's
girlfriend 51 year old shashonda darky
was arrested in september after she was
found trespassing at morpheus former
residence morpheu is charged with the
2020 death of his wife suzanne who was
last seen on mother's day of that year
though a body has never been found
colorado police say suzanne murphy is
presumed dead morphy is set to appear in
court virtually on tuesday for a status
conference
and in new hampshire missing
seven-year-old harmony montgomery's
stepmother faces new charges as she's
set to face a judge on thursday kayla
montgomery allegedly claimed the missing
girl on her food stamp benefits she is
now charged with a different felony than
she was first charged with theft by
deception and two misdemeanor counts of
acts prohibited for welfare fraud
kayla's estranged from her husband adam
who had custody of his daughter harmony
harmony's mother crystal sorry says she
last saw her daughter on a video call
near eastern 2019 but harmony wasn't
reported missing until last month over
the weekend investigators searched the
home where the seven-year-old lived with
her father he was arrested on charges
related to her disappearance he faces a
second-degree assault charge for
allegedly punching harmony in the eye in
2019 among other charges the reward for
information about her whereabouts has
reached a hundred thousand dollars
and the tiger king reality star expects
to receive less prison time for his
crimes out of re-sentencing hearing
schedule for the end of the month
joe exotic whose real name is joseph
maldonado passage is currently serving
22 years in prison for selling exotic
animals killing tigers and falsifying
wildlife records he is also convicted of
a murder for higher plot against
wildlife activist carol baskin in 2020.
in july an appeals court ruled that joe
exotic should have only been sentenced
to a maximum of 21 years and 10 months
in addition to joe exotic's case the
department of justice recently announced
that the couple who took over exotics
animal park are permanently banned from
exhibiting animals in november 2020 the
doj filed a complaint against jeffrey
and lauren lowe saying they were
violating the endangered species act
in late december after the lows violated
a preliminary injunction order several
times nearly a hundred endangered or
threatened animals were seized from the
facility
still ahead on law and crime daily a
judge denies the motion to dismiss
prince andrew's federal sex crimes trial
but first the state trial could be
pushed back in the case of three former
minnesota officers involved in the death
of george floyd all that and more after
the break
[Music]
hi this is dan abrams with exciting news
for all of our law and crime followers
on youtube you can now get the live law
and crime network with youtube tv for
all of your daily live trial coverage
legal news expert analysis and original
true crime programs subscribe to youtube
tv today and then locate law and crime
in the channel guide and for only 1.99 a
month you can add the network to your
bundle
watch lawn crime every day with youtube
tv we put you in the jury box
[Music]
welcome back to law and crime daily the
state trial for three former minnesota
police officers involved in george
floyd's death will likely be delayed
after the court grants a continuance
motion
on tuesday the court granted a request
made by all parties to continue the
trial of thomas lane jay alexander king
and tu tau a later to a later date the
motion was granted with specifications
that all parties must agree on a new
trial date by saturday and communicate
it to the court by sunday if a new date
has not been reported to court by sunday
the trial date will remain march 7th
earlier this week judge peter cahill
ruled video and audio recordings and
live streams will be allowed for the
state trial meanwhile a federal trial
for all three former officers is
scheduled to begin next week the ex-cops
and derrick chauvin were all indicted by
a federal grand jury last year for
allegedly depriving floyd of his civil
rights on may 25 2020. that day shoving
murdered floyd when he held him face
down on a ground handcuffed shovel was
convicted of floyd's death in june in
december he pled guilty to the federal
civil rights charges
let's bring back criminal defense
attorney taylor coss and terry austin to
discuss the latest in the three former
officers charged with violating george
floyd's civil rights terry is there any
significance that the federal case will
be tried before the state case could
this be an intentional move by the
defense
i think it was a great move by the
defense i think the federal case is
going to be more difficult to prove
against lane tau and king the criminal
case is fairly straightforward the
question really is did they use
reasonable force and so for that they
just have to look at whether or not tao
for instance he was holding the crowd
back did he act reasonably under these
circumstances king he had his knee on
george floyd's back was that reasonable
should he have stopped and lane had his
knee on the legs of george floyd so
those are all questions i think a jury
can answer quickly the federal case is a
little bit more difficult and more
complicated i think the question there
is whether or not these three officers
deprived george floyd of his
constitutional right so i think at the
end of the day it made more sense for
the defense to try to put off the
criminal case and to have the federal
case go forward versus the state case
now taylor is the federal case against
these three former officers just going
to be a repeat of the chauvin trial or
do you think we will hear more and even
different facts about this case
so i think at its core it's going to be
a repeat but when you get out from the
core and you start expanding you realize
uh that the subject matter in the
federal trial is broader
it's not as specific and it's not as
simple as did a do be you know which did
these people work together in in in a
goal to deprive a human being of a civil
rights it's a different standard it's
different elements and i anticipate
information
and evidence being heard by that jury
that has never been heard before by the
chauvin jury and would likely not be
heard in the state criminal matter right
unfortunately we won't actually
physically hear it because it's a
federal court case and so we can't put
cameras in there but we'll be here at
law and crime daily to give you that
gavel to gather coverage when that
federal trial does begin thank you both
coming up on law and crime daily
wisconsin defendant tests positive for
coppa 19 as he stands trial for the
murder of his parents
plus prince andrew is headed to federal
court why a judge says it's too soon to
dismiss the sex crimes trial against the
british royal
[Music]
welcome back federal prosecutors say
they will drop perjury charges against
former british socialite elaine maxwell
if her recent conviction sticks
prosecutors say it's to avoid the
victims from having to testify and go
through that trauma again
maxo was the former girlfriend of
jeffrey epstein a jury convicted her
last month on five of six sex crime
counts including sex trafficking of a
minor prosecutors say she and epstein
worked together to groom young girls for
sexual abuse the perjury charges stem
from a 2016 deposition on a civil case
where max was accused of lying those
charges were to be handled in a separate
trial prosecutors say they will dismiss
them if the defense's post-trial motions
are denied after the federal sex crimes
trial it came to light that one of the
jurors who convicted her had been
sexually abused and shared his story
during deliberations the defense says
that should grant maxwell a new trial
based on a supreme court ruling on
jurors failing to answer questionnaires
honestly
and the connection to the maxwell case a
sex assault lawsuit involving another
person tied to jeffrey epstein is moving
forward as another attempt to get it
thrown out fails
a judge has denied a motion to dismiss
the suit against prince andrew filed by
virginia du frey who is also an epscene
and maxwell accuser drew frey says the
british royals sexually assaulted her
when she was trafficked to him by
epstein and maxwell when she was 17.
prince andrew argued a 2009 settlement
drew frey made with epstein barred her
from suing him drew frey accepted a
payout of 500 000 from epstein and
agreed it would be confidential the
agreement also protects quote other
potential defendants that settlement was
reached a decade before epstein was
found dead in his jail cell the lawsuit
now moves into the discovery phase which
involves taking depositions if the case
is not settled it could move to trial
later this year
let's bring back criminal defense
attorney taylor causing co-host terry
austin to break down the latest in the
duke of york civil case terry what does
it mean that the defense didn't win
their motion to dismiss and does that
tell us anything about the strength of
duprey's case
well it means the case will be allowed
to go to trial and the judge basically
said that the complaint was
not vague and that it was not ambiguous
it was enough to move forward she
specifically alleged some sexual abuse
and she identified specific locations
virgin islands manhattan and london so
it shows that the case can go forward
but what it doesn't show brian it
doesn't say anything about the strength
of the case itself
now taylor does this civil case ever
going to end up in a trial do you think
we'll see prince andrew on u.s soil for
this case or will motions or a potential
settlement come up first
uh this will never ever go to trial if
it does there has been some sort of
crazy uh
horrible lawyering um he can't take that
risk the the public relations nightmare
that a trial would be for him whether
he's innocent or guilty quite frankly is
just a disaster for him and for the
royal family so whether this is based on
subsequent motions or a sealed and
closed settlement just never sees the
inside of a courtroom yeah i agree with
you taylor i'll probably one-up you
there as well i don't even think he's
going to sit down for a deposition
because
help him if those words ever see the the
the sunlight or the day anything like
you said the court of public opinion i
think would destroy him absolutely thank
you both when we come back the medical
examiner is called to testify as a
wisconsin man stands trial for the
murder and dismemberment of his parents
for lack of a better term mr halderson
was shot in the back that is correct
what gruesome details the medical
examiner reveals in the dismembered
parents trial that's next on long crime
daily
[Music]
welcome back to law and crime daily week
two of a wisconsin double homicide trial
comes to a screeching halt when the
defendant tests positive for cobin 19.
after quarter journeyed on tuesday news
broke that 23 year old chandler
halderson tested positive for the virus
this comes as the dane county jail where
halterson is being held reports a record
number of coven 19 cases jorus lunch is
on trial for the murder of his parents
50 year old bart and 53 year old crystal
holderson in july 2021.
prosecutors say halterson cut up their
bodies and attempted to burn their
remains in the family fireplace
halderson is also accused of scattering
parts of their bodies around southern
wisconsin on wednesday judge john halen
confirmed there was no motion for a
mistrial by either side ed that hollison
had been fully vaccinated for copen 19.
he told jurors court proceedings have
been delayed at least until next tuesday
someone essential to the proceedings has
tested positive and as a result everyone
who was in the well of the courtroom
on both sides
have taken steps to quarantine i know
other uh colleagues have tried and have
had to uh postpone or even
uh completely reschedule trials and i
think that may be something that occurs
further i asked for six alternates
because i was very concerned uh about
you folks during this process i hadn't
anticipated
that it could cause a delay as far as
others but there are essential
persons connected to these proceedings
and we are all undergoing uh routine
testing and monitoring of our health and
this is where we are at this point in
time
before news broke the kobe 19 diagnosis
on tuesday the prosecution called the
medical examiner to the stand who
performed the autopsy of victim bart
hardison's torso
can you make any determination whether
those that disfigurement or
dismemberment occurred before after mr
halderson bart holderson died
so one thing that helps us determine
whether or not an injury occurred before
or after death is the presence or
absence of a vital reaction or
hemorrhage so we've been talking about
me finding hemorrhage in areas of injury
in the areas where the gunshot entrance
was were there was hemorrhage around it
indicating that the heart was beating
when the
and the individual shot where i
recovered bullet fragments there was
hemorrhage or vital reactions
surrounding that area
however in the areas surrounding the
dismembered
limbs or the head the upper extremities
and lower extremities
there were injuries but i did not
appreciate this vital reaction i did not
appreciate hemorrhage in the same way
that i appreciate it around the other
injuries
so the
mutilation occurred after death
that is correct
doctor
did you determine a cause of death for
balt bart holderson i did
and what was that cause of death
as written on page two of my report i
determined the cause of death was
gunshot wounds of the torso
and did you determine of manner of death
i did
and what was the manner of death for
bart halderson as i'm reading from page
two of my report i assessed that the
manner of death was homicide
taylor how are the pre and post-humorous
humorous sorry injuries telling the
story of how bart hardison was murdered
well now we learn we've learned some
things today a we learned that the cause
of death was multiple gunshots to his
back so he was shot in the back and
that's what killed him we also learned
that the vicious and really absolutely
disgusting mutilation occurred
post-mortem um we don't have the same
answers for the mother we don't know
because we haven't recovered enough of
the body to make those determinations
yet but now we know for sure what
happened this was a shooting to the back
and then a mutilation postmortem and you
know both sides can use this information
to argue effectively now now terry what
happens if chandler holderson is not
cleared by the next court date for kova
19 could we see a mistrial
brian that's a distinct possibility you
know judge highland has been very
careful he's cautioned the jurors to
make sure they don't hear anything
outside of the courtroom but now that we
know they will be outside of the
courtroom for an indeterminate amount of
time they could very well hear something
either intentionally or not
intentionally about the trial and you
don't want that it's very important that
you protect that barrier because they're
only supposed to make their decision
based on what evidence they see in trial
and also the other issue is the longer
they're out the greater the possibility
that one of the jurors god forbid
themselves might get coveted and of
course that would be a problem as well
you'd have to get one of those
alternates to sit in and you could go
through quite a few alternates so
hopefully this you know delay will not
uh cause a mistrial but it very well
could brian
yeah it's an unfortunate reality that we
live in with coveted times and
attempting to try to have trials
affecting everyone well thank you both
and thank you for joining us here on law
and crime daily we'll see you next time
as we discuss justice in america
[Music]
[Music]
you